[Musique]
à cause des fantômes que nous apportons, nous
les servons même beaucoup et la plupart d'entre eux
sont à l'ouest
donc c'est des mouvements excessifs cette fois-ci.
[Musique]
nous les éclairons sur les dommages qui
sont causés par une bonne gestion des
déchets électroniques et
par exemple le  brûlant des câbles
jour et nuit, etc.,
ils savent exactement ce qui arrive à leur
corps lorsqu'ils font cela, donc ils sont
encouragés à faire les choses de la bonne manière,
ce qui est respectueux de l'environnement.
[Musique]
nous plaçons le profit avant les
gens que
nous  Si nous mettons le gain avant le bien commun
et ce n'est pas acceptable, il doit y avoir
des changements fondamentaux. J'espère que toute cette
question convoitée nous aidera à prendre
conscience que vous savez que la nature est une force
qui doit être harmonisée et dont il faut même prendre
soin.
[Musique]
donc
vous